uh and another thing i want to say is is
that um
today's episode don't be upset it's
gonna happen was supposed to be the bill
burr episode
um so bill texted us earlier today he
lost his voice
he lost his voice he even texted me lost
his voice he'll be here for two
in a couple of weeks right but i have to
say there's a
there's a bit of relief there i wanna
this is what i wanna um
tackle in this episode today what
why why do you think you fear bill so
much
the billboard yeah the bilber
i don't i don't fear nobody baby [ __ ]
your voice changed
hey dude wash it what's happening
no um fear is not the right one you just
revere him a lot i don't revere him at
all [ __ ] him oh [ __ ]
that's uh i dare you he's just a man
he's a man he's a man
i'll tell you why i'll tell you why
because um
and i'll bring it up when he's here uh
because it's steve byrne's fault the
core of everything
again i guess
it's it is steve burns fault right
because
uh um in 2004
i i was driving with steve byrne
in kenjung from san francisco
to l.a and in the ride
oh so steven got mad at me because i
threw his oasis cds out the window yep
well documented yeah it's well
documented and um
and so he would not have back then we i
think there was ipads and stuff and
not ipads but like i i
he was working with cds i don't know
maybe he was behind
and he only thing in the car was a bill
burst cd
wow and he goes well let's just listen
to
bill burr's comedy cd i'm like i didn't
ever heard of bill burr
okay right i just went no
[ __ ] it let's let's not listen to
anything
and he goes wait you don't know who bill
burr is and ken's like you don't know
bill burris i go
no right and like dude
he literally is like like the best
new york guy like you know you know
norton right yeah i guess
he's you know he's up there with him
and i go really so we listened and we
laughed
so hard and it also it's like you know
it i'll have to rem
it reminded me of when i first met
andrew schultz
you know when when i see you know
somebody that does something
that i don't know if i can do really
it intimidates me it's like i look you
know there's a lot of comics i look at
and i go
like i love paulie but when i look at
them on stage i don't
it doesn't intimidate me you know what i
mean because it's
it's around the same level of you know i
mean
what i can do you know what i mean but
when i see somebody that's like
you know honest right
he doesn't care he's really saying his
point of view
right and it's an interesting angle
right
or something that's brave for instance
you know that's kind of controversial
he doesn't care he'll back it up with
his you know with his jokes
and it's just honest and fresh and real
right
and these are things that i aspire to be
i want to be that
i do as a comic that's why i can't i
like i haven't done stand-up in the
pandemic because
i can use um the pandemic as a um excuse
but that's not it it's i know i have to
change
and i'm not willing to do it yet you
know so there's all these
things that you know um that bill
embodies
you know mean that i respect and but um
i don't know what it is i i you know i
know people that are bigger than him
that i'm not as intimidated by it's not
intimidation that's not the right word
it's more of a um
just respect you know and you know when
i'm around i'm not uncomfortable and we
talk and stuff you know
but it's like you know i don't know if i
would like go hot air ballooning with
him
does he do that i don't know no he
doesn't do it not just that they're
ballooning
maybe like ride a tram what's a tram
i think it's a thing that takes you to
disney world it's like a train but in
disneyland or at the glendale
um america i would do that with him i
would do that with him trained
the [ __ ] yeah like a five eight hour
train ride
in the same caboose what do they call
them what's a caboose
is it a butt something it's the back of
the truck oh no what's the little
compartment i think that's transpart
um sleepy car sleepy car sleeper sleepy
car yeah
but that's what it is that's what
i'll tell you this came out that's why
that happened
i like acai inside my throat
um but when he's here it's gonna be fine
it's gonna be a great episode i can feel
it you know
yeah but um do you feel like you have to
hold back certain things with him no
okay i'm not like that with anybody i
have so much reverence
around or for him that i'll probably
stay quiet
and just listen and take in the bobby's
nerves
that's what i want to take in but you
know what like dice
when dice was i had the same feeling
with him yeah
there's just something about dice that i
you know
i grew up watching um you know there's
another guy you know
although he probably won't come but he
would i think if we spray down the place
he is howie mandel we'd have to really
put everything in plastic and and really
have a
hazmat suits for him yeah but howie's
another one where i'm
when i'm around him i'm sorry it's just
the way i would i grew up watching them
and i'm a fan and i remember watching
like howie mindell
when i was a kid on hbo and he did yeah
i have a black hand he put a big black
like you know i mean actual head face
you know what i mean
and i remember as a kid that just struck
me as funny it was before
i'd ever seen prop comedy or anything
like that it was and it was so
zany up there and you you don't think as
a kid you go
you don't go oh i'm gonna i'm gonna
be at his house
really in your head right and then like
a couple weeks ago i did that thing with
him with the interview
and you know i was around him and i'm
i'm fine i'm as relaxed i
as him as i am with anybody else but
there's an
added little thing that i'm still a kid
and i'm still a fan of people and i'm
still like um
excited you know there's some people i
run into who are famous or who are
artists that i don't have that feeling
with it's like when paul banks texts me
you know what i mean i just kind of go
like a kid and i go
gee like i don't know why he
he [ __ ] texted me three days ago
about
about how he um listened to our podcast
and he said oh that was a really good
one
yeah i didn't know how to respond so i
go
i go did you vote
like why would i [ __ ] text that
so there is a list of people that make
you you know what i love doing with you
i love last night me dylan and steve
are playing war zone yeah white well
just listened all right
i knew i i i [ __ ] we're playing
warzone right
and then we hear blink right yeah gill
bits
that's your right yeah shout out is
asking to
requesting to play yeah